المخرج النجم محمد سامي يؤكد مركزه في
الصداره في جعفر العمده هو ورد الخال نجمه
للموت ثلاثه ومفاجاته وبين سوق الكانتو
والصفاره وقبلهم بالطو القدير محمود
البزاوي متالق اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
عشرات المسلسلات بتشارك في الموسم
الرمضاني هذه السنه مختلف المواضيع
والفئات والقصص وحقيقه يعني معظمها لها
جمهورها والناس المتابعه لها لكن لو
حنتكلم عن مسلسل واحد متصدر عربيا فما
بنبالغ لو قلنا انه جعفر العمده هذا العمل
اللي من بطوله محمد رمضان ومجموعه من
النجوم ومن تاليف واخراج المخرج النجم
ايضا محمد سامي واللي يعتبر او يعتبر هذا
تعاونه الثالث مع محمد رمضان في الدراما
وانا عملت ايه غلط في حياتي
بالاحرمني من عيال الاثنين
فاكره ان ربنا خلق الدنيا دي كلها عشان هو
بس
انت ورثت
وقفت قدام اهلي بعت كل حاجه في الدنيا
عشان خاطري
الخط العزاء في ودني انا مش عارف اعيش
والله عايزه اكمل الحكايه للاخر لو الواد
عايش رجعه لي
[موسيقى]
وريني فين
اللي خده
[موسيقى]
طيب شغلك الرقاصه هو كل واحد بيختار
فعليا كل حلقه ترند واحداث شاغله الناس
لحظه بلحظه ومقعدتهم مستنيين كل حلقه
بحلقتها هذا غير الشخصيات الرهيبه والجمل
اللي معلقه مع الناس يعني عمل متكامل
وبيثبت فيه محمد سامي انه الرقم الصعب في
الاخراج
وفي ظهور ما بيحصل كثير محمد سامي منورنا
اليوم في تفاعلكم اهلا فيكم معانا يا محمد
وكل عام وانتم بالف خير يا رب
اهلا وسهلا بك وكل سنه وانت طيبه وبخير يا
رب ورمضان كريم عليك وعلى كل المشاهدين
الكرام طيب يعني ما اكون ببالغ صراحه لو
اقول لك انه نحن كلنا هنا بنتابع جعفر
العمده الصراحه يعني ومستنيين حلقه بحلقه
وكل يوم حتى بنحكي مع بعض انه صفصف قالت
كده ثريا قالت كده وكل ده الكلام انت ايش
اللي خلاك من البدايه يعني تدخل في هذه
القصه ايش اللي حبيت تقوله
والله انا انا يعني في في كذا طريقه ببني
بها المسلسل انا بشوف دايما اني من زمان
في قصص معينه وفي مواضيع معينه في
اتموسفير معين هو بيكون انجح عربيه ومصريا
في في الدراما التلفزيونيه يعني دلوقتي في
منعطف اخر لشكل الحلقات الدراميه للبلاد
فورس والحاجات الجديده ولكن شكل شهر رمضان
بشكل المسلسل الدراما الرمضاني من زمان
جدا وهو الدراما المصريه لها اشكال كتير
بس في شكل ثابت رئيسي هو اللي بيكون اقرب
للجمهور او اقرب الاشتياق الجمهور لرمضان
وهي الحاره المصريه الحاره المصريه اللي
هي الحاره الشعبيه اللي فيها الوصول وفيها
القيم وفيها المبادئ ومن ناحيه ثانيه فيها
التناقضات وفيها الصراعات فيها فيها مجتمع
كامل الحاله المصريه فيها مجتمع كامل هو
عمره ما بيخلص وعمره ما هيخلص من الحواديت
ومن القصص
فدي اهم حاجه انا ببص عليها دايما يعني
لما جيت اعمل قصه جعفر لعمده بعد كده
شاركني السيناريو والحوار مهاب طارق وانا
من الاول واول حاجه قلتها
للراجل قلت له احنا احنا جوه الموت ده
احنا جوه الشكل ده احنا جوه البيت المصري
اللي في مصر وفي الوطن العربي بيحبوا
يتفرجوا عليه وعلى احداثه ومن هنا طلع
منطق الاتموسيه اللي اتعمل فيه جعفر
العمده بالنسبه للي عايز اقول ايه ضعف
العمده انا اتفضل
اللي انا عايز اقوله بجعفر العمده انا
بشوف ان المسلسل ال 30 حلقه بيكون
في مجال مش بكون حاجه واحده او مش بكون
بفكر في حاجه واحده عايز اقولها بيبقى فيه
طبعا رئيسيه وبيبقى فيه موضوع رئيسي انا
انا بمنشن فيه الفكره بتاعتي ولكن انا
شايف ان المسلسل بيتخللوا رسائل كثيره جدا
وبيكون في افكار كتير جدا الواحد عايز
يطرحها لها علاقه بالاخلاق ولها علاقه
بالتعاملات المجتمعيه ولها علاقه
بالاحترام وليها علاقه بالانتماء الاسري
ولها علاقه بحاجات كتير جدا من اكتر
الحاجات اللي انا بحب ادوس عليها دايما في
المسلسلات هي البرور مثلا فكره البرور
بالاسره فكره البرور بالام والاب
دي دي بكون حاجه قيمه عايز افكر الناس
بيها خاصه ان كنت في شهر رمضان وبكل ناس
قريبه بيفطروا على موائد في بيوت بعض في
بيوت اهلهم فبحب احيي القيم دي يعني طول
الوقت في مسلسلاتي من اول مسلسل لغايه
مسلسل جعفر العمده
محمد يعني الرائعه مي كساب يعني وصفتك
قالت انك انت مخرج الشعب يعني وانت قلت
انك انت يعني وصلت للتوليفه اللي بيفهموا
فيها او بتفهم فيها انه الناس ايش حابه
انت الان شرحت توليفتك بكل بساطه وبكل ثقه
ما بتخاف انه اذا يدخلوا عليك ناس ويعملوا
نفس التوليفه وينافسوك
[موسيقى]
انك انت بتكتب وبتخرج في نفس الوقت مو
متعب هذا الشيء بالنسبه لك يعني لو مثلا
جبت احد كاتب لك السيناريو وخلاص انت ركزت
في الاخراج
انا اتمنى ان طول الوقت في رحله البحث عن
سكريبت جيد
ولكن ما في احد بيغلبك في السكريبت الجيد
واضح انه حتى الان انت لا زلت متفوق في
الجيد
لا ممكن حد يغلبني ممكن حد يغلبني في
السكريبت الجيد وممكن حد يكتب سكريبت اجود
من السكريبت اللي انا هكتبه بس لغايه
دلوقتي
كان اقرب للي انا عايز اقدمه واقرب للنغمه
اللي بتريح ودن الناس على فكره محمد بشكل
عام انا معجبه جدا بثقتك في نفسك فوق شغلك
يعني وكل شيء بس احب جدا ثقتك بنفسك وكيف
تتكلم عن نفسك وكيف انت عارف قيمه نفسك
يعني بس خليني في سؤال محيرنا جميعا والكل
في الجاليري جالسين بيسالوه
الافيهات اللي في المسلسل الجمل اللي
بتطلع على لسان الممثلين انت كاتبها في
السكريبت من اول شيء ولا هي بتطلع معاكم
ولا ايش اللي بيحصل
لانت مكتوب على
وانا بعمل انا بشتغل مشهد من الاول بعمل
المشهد بقعد قبل ما اعمل اي حاجه خالص
بقعد انا وكل الممثلين بعد ما يلبسوا
يجهزوا بميكب في وش شعرهم وكل الشخصيه
تبقى قدامي يقعدوا قدامي وابدا وانا بشرح
الميزانسين بتاع المشهد او حركه المشهد
ببدا اقرا الممثلين المشهد مره الاول قبل
ما يبداوا هم يقروا ابدا اقرا المشهد مره
الاول وابدا وهم اما يبداوا يقروا قدامي
ابدا اقول طيب صفصف هتقولي هنا كذا طيب
جعفر هتقول هنا كذا ممكن حد من الممثلين
كمان يطلع بجمله لطيفه او بقفله لطيف ولكن
دائما ما بنبعدش عن محور المشهد بس ممكن
نحط افات لطيفه حالي
من الافهات اللي موجوده على على في
المسلسل دلوقتي هي طلعت في اللوكيشن
طلعتها في اللوكيشن واحنا قاعدين بنشتغل
والتعاون مع محمد رمضان يعني يبدو انه
كانكم مع بعض في فورمه لنجاح جميله يعني
رمضان رمضان اصل احنا خلاص دلوقتي احنا
الاتنين احنا اصحاب واخوات
وبنثق في بعض جدا وفي بالنا كمستري رهيبه
وشركاء نجاح دايما نجاحك مع الشخص بيخليكي
في بينك وبين الثقه وموده وحب واحترام
وهدوء في التفكير وكل حاجه فانا ورمضان
خلاص احنا بنشتغل دلوقتي كمان ارم يعني
احنا بنشتغل كشخص واحد خلاص احنا مش
بنشتغل كشخصين مع بعض او حد من ان انا
عايز يفرض وجهه نظره على الثاني او حد من
ان انا عايز يشوش تاني احنا بالعكس احنا
بنساعد بعض طول الوقت ان احنا الاتنين في
مركب واحد عايزين نسعد الجمهور بننزل
الصبح من البيت عايزين نسعد الجمهور ونروح
عايزين نسعد الجمهور واحنا كميتنا في
التفكير في المواضيع قريبه بحد كبير جدا
لبعض ده اللي مريحنا من البدايه يعني
الان بدات الحلقات يعني طبعا خلاص كل يوم
بيتفاعلوا معاها الناس وترند وكذا كثير
ناس رجعوا شبهوا المسلسل بعائله الحجم
متولي للراحل طبعا الكبير نور الشريف الله
يرحمه بتحس في تشابه ولا هي بس فكره
الاربع زوجات يعني
واصل المسلسل بتاعي مش بيحكي عن الاربع
زوجات يعني هو هو في اول حاجه رحمه الله
الاول الاستاذ نور الشريف الرحمه ونقول
للناس عليه الفاتحه في شهر الفضيل ده
استاذنا الكبير اللي تعلمنا منه
والله لو الناس هتشبهني باستاذ نور الشريف
فوق راسي لو الاستاذ لو الناس هتشبهني
باعمال العظماء دول انا فوق راسي ولكن هو
انا مسلسلي مش بيحكي عن زوج واربع نساء زي
الحج متولي انا مسلسلي بيحكي عن اب ضايع
منه ابنه يعني لما نيجي نحكي جعفر العمده
في سطر هنقول موضوع اني راجل متجوز من
اربع ستات ده مش من المين مش المين بلس
المين بلوت عن راجل بيدور على ابنه وعايز
يعرف مين اللي عمل فيه كده مين اللي اجر
بلال شامه عشان يخطف ابنه مش بحكي عن شخص
عنده اربع ستات وايه موضعهم تاني حاجه انا
انا كنت يعني لما جيت عملت المسلسل انا
بعرف دائما ان الناس لما بيبقى في علامات
مهمه وانت تتشابهي معاها في بعض النقاط
انا كنت منتظر الناس تقول اكتر في الاول
ان هو يشبه الحاج متولي ولكن على فكره ما
اخذش الكومنت ده وقت طويل او ما اخذش حيز
من الموضوع لان كانت الناس اتشغلت في
الموضوع يعني يمكن الحكايه دي اتقالت لما
اعلن عن فكره المسلسل في الاول ولسه الناس
ما دخلتش في تفاصيله بس انا فعلا ما حسيتش
بده كنت بتكلم انا ومحمد رمضان في ده بقول
له والله انا حسيت ان الموضوع ده لم ياخذ
صدى هو فعلا المسلسل مش هنا مش في المنطقه
دي ولو هو هيشبه المسلسل مع كامل الاحترام
انا هقدم ليه مسلسل اتقدم شبهه قبل كده
يعني يعني مش من قله المواضيع او من قله
الافكار يعني هي يبدو مشهد لما جاب لهم
زينه على البيت هو ده اللي ربط عند الناس
المسلسلات مع بعض لما هي طبعا زوجته
الرابعه محمد انا بدي استغل وجودك معانا
واسالك كم سؤال كده سريعين على بعض
الاشياء المتداوله بين الناس اذا ممكن ترد
لنا عليها وتوضحها واحده من الاشياء
الكثير ناس علقوا عليها انك انت طبعا رجعت
الفنانه لبنى ونيس صغيره ورجع طبعا محمد
رمضان صغيره وصاروا الناس بيسالوا انت جبت
ممثله ثانيه ولا ما شفت احنا الان شايفين
الصوره امامنا على الشاشه يعني هل انت جبت
ممثله ثانيه ولا انت ايش عملت بالضبط
[موسيقى]
قبل ما نبدا المسلسل نفسه عشان نوصل
للنتيجه فلما شفت ان الموضوع عمل ترند
والناس علقت عليه في ريحت جدا جدا لانه
نتاج مجهود فعلا كان كبير وانه كان اول
مره يتعمل يعني هو اول مره يتعمل الحمد
لله في الوطن العربي وما كنتش عايز اعمله
عادي من انا اصغرهم بمجرد ميك اب واحط ميك
اب وخلاص وحبه صفطس على الوش ما بيبقاش
جربت عملت ده قبل كده بس ما كنتش مبسوط
بجد اعيش المشاهد بجد جوه الحاله فعلا لا
المره دي ظبطها خليني اقول لك على تعليق
اخر برضو بيتكرر اسمك على التتر بيتكرر ست
مرات يا محمد
لا هو هو مش بيتكرر ست مرات هو عشان انا
مخرج وعامل القصه وعامل السيناريو والحوار
انا ومهاب فيعني طيب يعني
وفي الاخر اكتب قصه احمد نجيب بس انت
بتحطه في الاول وبترجع في الاخر
انا بعمل كده من ادم اوكي لاني احيانا في
رمضان لما بتكتر الاعلانات بيتقص التتر هو
لما بيتقص بيتبقى منه للجزء الاولاني يا
الجزء الاخير انما هو مش موجود دايما طول
الوقت وبعدين وبعدين انا بقعد اعمل في
المسلسل بشتغل عليه تقريبا سبع ثمان شهور
ما بيتبقاش ليا فيه غير اسمي اللي على
التتر فمش عارف ايه ده حد في وجود القسم
بس تمام
كتير شويه عشان انا بعمل ثلاث حاجات في
المسلسل لا حلو حلو خلاص مسلسل برضو يلا
حط اسمك فين ما تبغى فيه محمد كمان واحده
من الاشياء امي بتفرح يعني امي اكتر حاجه
بتفرحها هي وابويا الاسم ده
اكتبه لها 10 مرات اذا نحط طول المسلسل حط
تحت كده على جنب طول المسلسل ما اكل الله
يخليك يا رب ويفرحهم فيك دائما طيب محمد
كمان واحده من الاشياء كانوا صار في
احتفال واجتمعتوا كلكم انتم نجوم العمل
وكان واضح الانسجام والحب بينكم بس كان في
غياب للنجمه زينه وقيل انه في خلافات في
خلافات
هو ما كانش في احتفال هو ده كان
السحور دعينا الى السحور بتاع شركه
الانتاج
والله من الحاجات اللي بسطتني قوي ان احنا
لما دخلنا السحور لقينا احتفاء زمايلنا في
المسلسلات الاخرى بينا ولقينا احتفاء من
الصحافه واحتفاء من الناس فما بتدخلي
بتحسي يعني احنا كنا تقريبا مش عارف يوم
اربعه رمضان او ثلاثه رمضان او رمضان يعني
لسه احنا لسه في الاول بس حسينا بفرحه
الناس بالمسلسل وحسينا بفرحه زمايلنا لينا
فرحتنا لهم
فتحول الشكل العام الى احتفال من الناس
بينا والله وبعدين رمضان خلينا نتفق ان
رمضان وجوده بيعمل حاله برده بصراحه
واستاذه هاله صدقي ومي و و و وايمان ومنه
فضالي واحمد داش وفهيم واحمد عبد الله ونش
كلنا كنا موجودين
فكره ان رمضان بيغني كمان فبقى المايك
راحوا للناس ادوا المايك لرمضان في رمضان
بيغني فحسوا الناس ان هو احتفال انما احنا
كنا في السحور بتاع شركه الانتاج
[موسيقى]
خلاص مش عايز تضيف اضافه تانيه على اللي
بدات فيه انا السؤال
انا اسف معلش كان ايه السؤال كان فين زين
زين انا زعلانه منكم فعلا في خلاف ولا لا
لا ما اعرفش لا ما اعرفش والله هي انا ما
اعرفش ممكن تكون عندها حاجه او ممكن تكون
مش موجوده انا معرفش يعني ايه هو هو بيدعو
كل واحد مننا لشخص يعني كل واحد يوصل له
لشخصه ممكن تبقى
شخص الاحترام طب انت انت شخصيا ما بينك
وبين اخي لا يعني
لا طبعا ليه خلاف ليه اعوذ بالله بالعكس
يعني الست بطلت مسلسلي وعامله شغل جميل
جدا وانا مبسوط بالشغل ولا بالعكس ليه في
خلاف اعوذ بالله الحقيقه صراحه يا محمد
انت يعني يوميا بنستنى الحلقه يعني فعليا
ما ببالغ يعني رائع رائع رائع المسلسل
مسلي بشكل
رهيب وصراحه كل الكاست رائع بلغهم كلهم
تحياتنا وتحيه كبيره كبيره لصف صف تحديدا
يعني كمان
استاذه يا استاذتنا الكبيره اللي تشرفنا
بيها وتشرفنا بالشغل معاها رائع رائع كلكم
رائعين في المسلسل احنا مستنيين الاحداث
طبعا كيف حتصير في النهايه بشكرك جدا يا
محمد على ظهورك معنا اليوم وانك شكرا انا
كمان يعني اخترت انا وطلعت معنا في
تفاعلكم وكل التوفيق في كل الاعمالك كان
معنا طبعا النجم المخرج محمد سامي من
القاهره شكرا لك
في الجزائر مسلسل الدراما الاجتماعيه
الدامه اللي بيعرض على التلفزيون الجزائري
وبيتكلم عن الصراعات في احد احياء العاصمه
هذا المسلسل المتصدر الاخبار والسبب اصدار
سلطه ضبط او السلطه الضبط السمعي او ضبط
السمع البصري بيان طالبت في التلفزيون
الحكومي بتوضيحات عن مشهد في اولى حلقات
المسلسل المشهد المقصود في البيان هو مشهد
بيظهر في جدار باحد اسواق الجزائر العاصمه
مكتوب عليه كلمه الماك يمكن لغير
الجزائريين مو واضح فين المشكله في الكلمه
المشكله انه الماكوه اسم لحركه تقرير
المصير في منطقه القبائل وتسمى ايضا حركه
الماء وهي منظمه سياسيه بتسعى للحكم
الذاتي والانفصال لاقليم القبائل في
الجزائر وتاسست عام 2001 وصنفتها الحكومه
الجزائريه في 2020 حركه ارهابيه فلما
الناس لاحظت ظهور الكلمه وصار الجدل قامه
السلطات وطالبت التلفزيون الحكومي بتوضيح
وقال انه راح تتخذ الاجراءات اللازمه بناء
على التوضيحات التلفزيون الجزائري الي
للان ما في منه اي رد
[موسيقى]
النجمه اللبنانيه ورد الخال بتطل على
الجمهور في الموسم الرمضاني بدور بطوله
ضمن مسلسل للممثلاثه ودورها هو دور كارما
سيده الاعمال صاحبه الشخصيه القويه زوجه
الام القائده لعصابه مافيا طويله عريضه
بتخوض فيها حرب مع اخوها واللي بيتابع
للممثلات راح يعرف انه ورد او كارما في
هذا الجزء محرك اساسي للاحداث ولعمل كل من
سحر اللي بتادي دورها طبعا النجمه ماجي
بوغصن وريم واللي بتادي دورها النجمه
دانيال رحمه وللتذكير مسلسل الموت
لوموسيمين رمضانيين وقدر يجمع حوالينه
كثير من المحبين والمتابعين والمتشوقين
لاحداثه ويبدو انه الجزء الثالث حكايته
مختلفه والمواجهه راح تكون نسائيه وفي
تونس
تحيات مثل البيانو
عقد ما تاخدي منها عقد ما بتعرفي تلعبي
انا ربيت بعائله
حاسه حالي وحيده
علمتني انه شك بكل الناس اللي حواليا
انا محلك كمان بضلوعي
وتنضم الينا من بيروت النجمه ورد الخال
اهلا فيك معنا يا ورد منورتنا اليوم كل
عام وانت بالف خير يا رب
رمضان كريم منوره بوجودكم الله يخليكي
صراحه تمام والسنه يعني لما شفنا اسمك
وانضمامك للعمل قلنا اوف يعني الموضوع رح
يكبر بس انت كورد الخال لما نجو قالوا لك
تعالي انضمي لنا في السيزون الثالث يعني
عاده الواحد بيخاف اذا ما كان موجود من
البدايه حسيت بهذا الخوف
حسيت بالمسؤوليه
حسيت
يعني
كيف بدي اقول الحشريه حتى عارف شو هو
الدور اول من عرض علي يعني
زي فضول يعني بس عشان اللي ما يعرف معنى
الكلمه فضوله وحب استطلاع يعني طبعا
كان كل فريق العمل عم بيقول لي انه انت
لازم تكوني بهذا الجزء لانه
دور دور حلو
ولازم تعرف فاكيد تحمست انا وخاصه انا
شاغله مع شركه ايجون فيلمز اعمال عديده
يعني
فاخدت اخدت النص وقرايته وكتير تحمست
وكتير حبيت شخصيه كارما هلا هي مكروهه بكل
الوطن العربي بصراحه يعني انا هذا الشيء
حابه يعني اقدر افهمه منك يعني ورد كيف
عامله شخصيه وحده هذا القد شريره وهذا
القد كريهه بس في نفس الوقت محافظه على
هدوءك وكلاس كيف كيف عملتيها
عملتيها عملناها هي مكتوبه على الورق
امراه عندها جبروت عندها قوه عندها سلطه
ولكن امراه يعني عندها بتوصل لاهدافها
بطرق ملتويه كونها هي شغلها شغل من
يعانوني من هالبزنس مو من اللي بتشتغل
بشكل قانوني طبعا هي هي قائده
مافيا
والى اخره
حبيت انه اصورها بطريقه بعيده عن شيء مره
الشريره اللي بتبين لا هي امراه
بتعزف بها نوم في كثير نماذج
بمجتمعاتنا بيكونوا مرتبين وحلوين
وانيقين بس هن ياما تحت السواهد قولي لي
حتقولي لي
نقدر نجلس نحط القهوه ونحكي على الموضوع
فتره ط
اكيد يعني هيك تصورتها يعني وشفتها وطبعا
مع الحديث مع الكيك بنادين جابر قالت له
هي اللي انا هيك بتخيلها فقلت لها عظيم
طبعا مع المخرج الاسمر نحن هالثلاثه
رسمنا شخصيتها شكلا ومضمونه البادي لانج
تبعها صوتها الى اخره انه امراه بتقدر
توصل للي بدها اياه وما في شي صعب عندها
ورايقه
شفناهم هيك شفناها
ورد ولا في احد ثاني بيعزف
انا انا مش انا هدول مش اصابيع اوكي لانه
قلت كمان لو طلعت تعزف بيانو كمان يعني
بزياده كمان الموضوع طيب
وحلو طبعا بس ورد يعني كمان صراحه لمن
اوكي ورد الخال ما غصن دانيلا رحمه يقولوا
دائما الستات ما يعرفوا يشتغلوا مع بعض
ولازم تصير بينهم مشاكل وافلام انتم ما
شاء الله ثلاثه اسامي قويه في عمل بطوله
نسائيه مطلقه يعني كيف مش الوضع
يعني شو بدي اقول لك احلى الاوقات متعه
فعلا احلى الاوقات اربعه اشهر ونص تقريبا
ليل نهار عم نشتغل بقلب بقلبه شو بقولوا
بعشق وبيشغف طبعا كانوا كمان كثير مرحبين
كانوا كانوا
حاضنينني بشكل كثير كبير وهن بشخر يعني كل
حدا منهم كان محمص لدوري بشكل كثير كبير
عشقانين دور كارما
الحماس موجود على
نضحك كثير بهالمشاهد هدول نحن اصحاب
اصدقاء في الف كثير اشتغلنا بقلب واحد
يعني
ولو ما هيك ما كان طلعت هيدي النتيجه مع
انه نحن اللي بيشوفنا مع بعض بشوفنا
بالشخصيات
بيكرهوا بعض كثير
الدم للركب يعني
بالحقيقه ما فيني اقول لك شو كان الجو حلو
وشو زعلنا انه خلص المسلسل خلص هيدا الشغل
يعني لا
بتواصل مستمر
بنحكي عن عن كواليس العمل وكل حدا منك جزء
رابع
نعم هل نتوقع جزء رابع
يمكن ما بعرف يعني هذا الشيء بيرجع للشركه
الانتاج وللقيمين وللمحطه ما بعرف الحقيقه
ما بعرف حب يكون فيه
مشاهد وكنتابعه للعمل اكيد بحب بس مش
بالضروره اكيد تكون بالجزء الرابع هو جميل
يعني يمكن ينتهي دورك هذا الجزء
[موسيقى]
يعني
اوكي صح صح لانه الثالث
الجزء الثاني قفلنا انه ماتوا كانوا رجعوا
فكل شيء ممكن يعني
ثالث ث
الث جزء ثالث لكن انه انا كحضوري بجزء
رابع بقصه ما بعرف تكون بس مش يعني ما بعد
هيدا بكير الحكي عليه الحقيقه
اللي بعرفه انه دائما هن عندهم تحدي انه
يعملوا اشياء جديده ودائما هم بينتروا رد
فعل الجمهور كل الظروف يعني لحتى يخوضوا
هالتحدي مره ثانيه يعني بس انا اكيد بتكون
من المتابعين
يعني خلاص انا بحس صرت فرد من من هالعمل
هذا من هالمشروع
ورد ما في ما في
بس ما في صراحه بدي يعني ما بدي اعدي
الوقت بلا ما اسالك انه من اول حلقه واحنا
جالسين بنتابع ملابسك صراحه
وشكلك بشكل عام يعني ما شاء الله عليك كيف
محافظه على هذا الجسم ما شاء الله عليك
والملابس
بعمل رياضه كثير
باكل كثير وبعمل رياضه كثير مع بعضهم ههه
تاكلي كم طولك يا ورد بس اكيد
انا بس كنت
[موسيقى]
اطلع بعيده كليا عن شخصيه الحقيقيه طبعا
هيدا هدفي وهذا التحدي لالك كثير اشخاص
ورا هاللوك اللي عم يلي لا اعجاب عند
الناس
طبعا اكيد في جنود مجنونين بس هن ويكابونه
مثل رولا سليمان
فريق يعني
طبعا ورده حاولت اني استفيد يعني من اللي
انت نصيحتك في هذا الموضوع لكن مش راح
تمشي معايا احتاج اسال احد ثاني اشوف احد
ثاني غيرك ههه طيب لكن شكرا لك متالقه
متالقه متالقه اعطيتي للموت كمان طعم
اضافي جديد شكرا لك كانت معنا من بيروت
النجمه ورد الخال
محمود البزاوي اسم بيضيف لكل عمل بينضم له
حقيقه مهما طالت دور او قصر تمثيل وتعابير
وجمله بتحول اي لقطه او شخصيه طلع فيها
ولو لثواني لمقطع بتتذكروا الناس وبتعلق
عليه وفي هذا الموسم الرمضاني بيطل علينا
محمود الوزاوي في مسلسل اولهم سوق الكانتو
بيؤدي فيه دور المعلم شحاته عم طه اللي
بيعملو النجم امير كراره واللي بيعتبروا
من اهم تجار الاقمشه في السوق وبيتعرضوا
للصراعات ومنافسات مع التجار الاخرين
حسنين القماش هيفضل كبير السوق حتى لو
صبيان وكده رجلهم شدت وقفوا على حيلهم بقى
عندهم دكاكين وصبيان برضو هيفضل كبير
السوق واحنا ما بنسيبش حقنا
في شغلنا ولا في شغل السوق نفتح لهم
الدكان عشان يمسكوا في خناقه فيها كل يوم
على مصلحته اهرسهم اما العمليه الثانيه
اللي بيطول فيه محمود البزاوي فهو الصفاره
وبيكون اخر دور الاب الفرفوش جمال اللي
يعني ولد وشفيق بيسرق صفاره الملك توت عنخ
امون وبتخليه يرجع الزمن او يرجع الزمن
ثلاث دقائق والرجوع من بعدها للحاضر
واكتشاف التغييرات والمغامرات فمن القاهره
ينضم الينا النجم القدير محمود البزاوي
اهلا فيك معانا يعني خليني ابتدي اول شيء
من قبل حتى رمضان الحالي انا يعني اذا بدي
اقول لك انه جزيره غمام يعني من اروع
الاعمال صراحه وكان فعلا مسلسل جميل جدا
جدا جدا رمضان الماضي بس ما سرحت لنا
الفرصه نتكلم رمضان الماضي فهنبتدي برمضان
الحالي وخلينا نبتدي من سوق الكانتو
تحديدا ايش اللي جذبك في هذا العمل
[موسيقى]
كبيره جدا يعني والموضوع
انا بحب قوي قوي يعني يسعدني جدا عن الحظ
لما اشتغل في مسلسل قماشته عريضه قوي كده
بيبقى في مباراه تمثيل وفي
والمخرج بيبقى مبدع في شغله وفي ادواته
وبيبقى كل الممثلين في غيره غيره الابداع
غيره التفوق يعني
ده كان موجود في جزيره غمام وموجود
في سوق الكانت صحيح يعني هو زيي كانه يعني
فعليا زي ما بتوصفها هي مباريات بس نحن
كجمهور ما بنحس انه في تنافس بتحس انه لا
الاداء خرافي فعلا يعني ويمكن هذاك يعني
دور جديد عليك حضرتك
لا هو يعني
يمكن عملت حاجات قبل كده فيها شبه شويه
ده يعني
ده انا حاسس انه قريب قوي من البيوت يعني
يعني قريب قوي من الناس والناس عندهم
دائما النموذج ده في في العائلات الموجود
فيها او اديت
يعني قريب انا حابه جدا يعني
ومتفائل به يعني يا رب ابقى شرير بالشكل
ده وانجح مع الناس يعني زي ما كنت في
الصفاره لطيف برده يعني شرير قريب على
القلب تبغى تكون طيب ههه بس
الصفاره يعني انا اتعب واقول لك انه قد
ايش انت الاب المثالي الجميل اللي يعني
صراحه الواحد هو بيتفرج على الصفاره بيحس
يقول انه ايش الاب الرائع هذا هل انت اب
رائع مع ابنائك لو سالنا هم لو سالناهم مش
انت
افندم لو سالناهم هم رايهم اه طبعا هم
اللي يقولوا ده يعني بس انا اولادي ان انا
في حاجات كتير جدا ما عرفتهاش في حياتي
وبقينا في زمن دلوقتي هم عارفين اكتر مني
بمراحل كتير جدا
فكرتنا دايما عن الاب ان الاب هو اللي
بيمتلك الحقيقه المطلقه وهو اللي عارف كل
حاجه والحاجات دي كلها ما ده بيفيدنا
حاجات كتير جدا في المعرفه فانا اعملهم هم
الاب يعني اعملهم هم الكبار بالنسبه لي
وهم اللي بيقولوا لي وهما اللي انا بسالهم
مش منتظر هم يسالوني لان هم هيسالوني في
زمانهم انا غالبا يعني زمانهم مش ملم دي
قوي يعني فعشان بينا وبين بعض علاقه
مش اصحاب قد ما هي علاقه
متفاهمين يعني دمنا واحد يعني كده عارفاه
يعني على قد بعض قوي
عجبتني جدا هذه الفلسفه بس على سيره
المشهد اللي احنا عرضناه لك مع ابنك وانت
بترقصوا ومش عارفه ايش والكلام ده كله
ابنك قال انك انت بتسوي معاه نفس الحركات
وانتم وهو صغار فهو كتب بوست حتى بيوصف
انه هذا المشهد فعليا كان بيحصل انت كنت
بتعمل معاهم كده برفع اليد بترفع ايدك
ويلا وهات يا رقص كده
ودائما من ورا مامتهم يعني يعني كنت دايما
اعمل ده من ورا مامتهم لحد ما هي اقتنعت
فبقيت اعمله قدامها عادي جدا
اه عشان اصحيهم من النوم يروحوا المدرسه
انا عارف قد ايه اللحظه دي بتبقى صعبه
شويه عند يعني فدائما اقرب من ودانهم كده
واقعد اقول لهم احكي لهم حكايه بهمس شديد
جدا لحد ما يفوق يعني هقول له طب مين حط
المشبك جوه
المحفظه بتاعتي
هيلاقي حاجه غير منطقيه بتوصلوا في ودنه
كده فيقول لي ايه اقول له ايوه المحفظه
بتاعتي انت مين انت
يلا نقوم بقى علشان
[ضحك]
انه الامور لازم خلاص تكون اوكي يعني تمام
وفي العالم
لا يعني انا مش مش مضبطه انا انا طبيعتي
كده انا ما بحبش يعني امارس دور الاب لاني
مش عارف يعني فكرتي عن دور الاب مش الفكره
بتاعه الاب اللي هو عارف وفاهم وكل حاجه
في الدنيا وبتاع لا انا لسه عايز اعرف
كثير جدا ففرصه ان ربنا مديني ولاد
بيعرفوا
وبيفهموا وشايفين كويس جدا ففرصتي ان انا
اعرف من خلالهم احسن كتير جدا انهم يعرفوا
من خلال وحسيت انه هذا الشيء ممكن تعمله
في الصفاره
اه لا ما هو احمد امين يعرف اكرم كويس
وعرفني كويس فقال لي ما تعمل تجربتك مع
اكرم ومع البيت معي قلت له اعمل ايه يعني
من حياتك جايه بالفكره
لا هي شبه اوكي على الورق وهو بيكتب هو عن
الحكايه احمد عنده نفس الفلسفه في ربايته
للولاد فقال طب ما اجيب محمود البزاوي لان
علاقته باكرم كمان قريبه والحاجات دي كلها
فانا كنت مبسوط جدا وانا بعمل ده يعني انا
حاسس ان انا طبيعي جدا
وهو المشهد يعني حتى اللي كنت بتتكلم فيه
لما كان بيقول لك ابنك انه يعني لو انت
ليه ما تروح وتجيب لنا سياره وتشتغل برا
وتجيب لنا سياره والكلام ده كله فسرت انت
تذكره بالاشياء اللي انت بتسويه معاها وقد
ايش هي حتى بسيطه بس انه هي هذه فعلا
الابوه انك تكون موجود في هذه التفاصيل
يعني على فكره هذا المشهد انا اقول لكل
احد يشوفه ويرجع يشوفه لانه فعلا مؤثر
يعني فعلا فعلا مؤثر جميل يعني جدا
[موسيقى]
استاذ محمود انا حابه بس اني ما يعني
انتهز فرصه وجودك واتكلم معك عن بالطو
لانه تجربه مختلفه تماما المسلسل هذا ما
حد توقع هذا النجاح نجاح منقطع النظير ايش
اللي صار في هذا العمل
الناس شافوها لمستهم بشكل كانهم بيتفرجوا
على حاجه يعني حاجه تسجيليه قوي
وعمر المهندس اللي هو المخرج قدر يعمل
حاجه اقرب
للواقع او لتفاصيل الواقع وحتى البطل
البطل كان بالنسبه لنا جديد جدا يعني وشبه
الشخصيه قوي وشبه احمد هو المؤلف يعني
الاثنين شبه
التجربه من من طبيعيتها او الشديده احنا
ما كناش متخيلين انها هتيجي كذا يعني او
النجاح الشكل ده او هتوصل بالشكل ده لكن
الحمد لله مبدئين جدا وحابين جدا وعمر
المهندس مخرج عنده حس كوميدي ما كانش
موجود من ايام عمو فطيم عبد الوهاب يعني
فانا ما فيش حد بيقول اف ايه خالص لكن بي
هو بان رده فعل الجمهور يعني على مسلسل ما
كان معمول له كثير دعايه وكذا الشكل
والنجاح الرهيب ده واضح جدا نحن بنشكرك
جدا على هذه المداخله معانا اليوم نورتنا
ان شاء الله المره الجايه بنجيك القاهره
لانه حاسه انه من وراك في مكتبه رهيبه احب
اني افتش في الكتب يعني اللي فيها شكرا لك
كان معنا النجم القدير محمود البزاوي شكرا
لك
مشاهدينا وصلنا لختام حلقه اليوم انا اعود
والقابكم الاسبوع المقبل ان شاء الله في
امان الله
[موسيقى]